Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in on.
Yeah,
just checking in to see how your week's going.
This isn't enough.
This never is.
Nor is it ever meant to be an official podcast.
All right.
I'm just fucking,
just,
just popping in real quick.
Little fucking half hour,
you know.
See now your workouts.
Go and seeing how you drive home still.
When are you listening to at work?
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
God bless you.
If he can get away with it.
I woke up today.
Butoh Lou Dude,
and I've,
I've had this fucking song in my head and I,
you might want to fast forward,
I forget how the lyrics go.
Was something like,
so,
uh,
give you a kiss after the loving Bada Doo Doo bop bop,
bop Bam.
Who Sang that song data?
Jude.
That's one of those fucking guys
who's probably,
you know when he recorded it is younger than I am,
but when I look him up,
he's going to look like he's 106.
Let's see after the love and lyrics.
You guys remember that one?
Oh,
oh.
Engelbert Humperdinck
yeah.
Engelbert Humperdinck where the fuck is the Millennium Collection?
The millennial collection.
Can we have a theories of songs that are safe for everybody?
Could that be okay?
Sorry.
Get my shitty recorded them on the road here.
Um,
just for the millennials.
Oh,
it's so as sing you to sleep after the Loven with this song I just wrote yes.
The day.
And I hope you can hear what the worlds and the Busey I again.
Well,
I don't know the rest of the fucking song goes.
That's one of those songs.
All you know is after the loving and you just sit there mumbling along
after 11,
right?
Oh fuck.
Oh my God.
That just reminded me of a fucking joke.
I want to do
a,
wait a second.
I gotta write this down.
Sweet Caroline.
Fuck you.
Cunt.
Uh,
red socks.
I got s one of the most stressful gigs.
This is the last stressful Gig I have all year.
I got past all the fucking press,
you know what I mean?
So all the press I had to do for that fucking thing.
You sit down,
you like,
how's this gonna go?
I was this one guy was that one going to go and you get all through it,
right?
I had a bunch of fucking,
you know,
I did that Gig for the cops.
The motorcycle cops in California got somehow got through that one.
I wasn't sure how that was going to go.
That one ended up going great.
I got one last fucking thing.
And once I get past this Gig,
I have nothing but comfort zone gigs for the rest of my year.
Today I'm on a roast,
they're retiring.
David Ortiz is number and uh,
he wanted to have a roast for his,
um,
for his charity.
And what's hilarious is I don't think he's going to understand most of the shit.
Like he,
one of the comedians he was talking to said,
you know,
I went out,
I laughed.
One of the people laughing,
but you talk real fast.
I don't understand what a lot of it is.
It's fucking,
which I understand.
Cause if I went to the Dominican Republic and they started roasting me,
I'd be like,
Eh,
I just keep waiting for him.
A roll hall.
That's the word I'd be waiting for.
Are they talking about
Cabeza?
Roho whatever the fuck they gonna say.
Oh [inaudible] how the fuck you saying I don't know.
So,
um,
I got some good ones.
Uh,
how do you roast David Ortiz?
You know,
fucking grumps there.
Uh,
Petrolia is going to be there and you know,
these are all athletes that play for Boston teams.
So all of them have won championships.
That's just how it is around here.
People,
this isn't like your towns were roasting one or your local athletes three out of
the four sports.
You know,
maybe you won one championship.
It'd be a fucking joke.
See what other city would be hard?
New York,
you could fucking destroy people.
Fucking destroy people.
Cause I don't think there's anybody left on the Yankees
and that God knows football team's turnover.
You couldn't really fun.
I mean,
Ely,
they'd always just make fun of how he looks at me to get trashed.
And next trash,
the mets trashed and Rangers
those Brooklyn fucking teams
that had to be like a two part fucking roast Pittsburgh be a hard place.
You know,
that'd be a hard place by,
maybe you can trash the pirates,
but I mean fucking penguins back to back.
And they've won.
They've won three with Crosby
big bands one too.
And you know,
a bunch of his shit would be taken off to test how it works.
They take it off the table.
I don't know that I'm talking about that.
Hey.
Yeah.
Hey,
could you not?
Um,
so anyways,
I just have to get through this,
so I figure I'm going to sit there and get called a cancer patient for fucking
an hour.
Uh,
they'll make fun of my black wife and then I just,
all I gotta do is just go up there for 10 minutes.
Yeah.
Trash David Ortiz.
I mean,
it's going to be fun.
I still want to tell you some of the jokes,
but I know [inaudible] got a tweet them and then people will read them before I
get there.
And I need every laugh I can get.
I'm,
I literally was fucking writing the shit.
Like I can't sit down and write.
I can't do it,
you know,
let's think of how I read out loud.
Okay.
Now imagine me trying to put those words down onto a piece of paper.
Um,
how I do it is I put my daughter in the stroller and I walk around the block,
a big huge walk around the block and I'm just talking to myself and everybody
thinks,
oh,
look at that.
Daddy's so engaged with this child and I'm really coming up with roast jokes.
And then I sat down and I smoked a cigar by myself on my back porch and I just
video myself and I just say shit into my fucking,
then I'll have like 40 videos all like nine,
10 seconds long.
And then I just transcribed them on the plane.
Uh,
most of them now I'm trying to put them into an order where they flow and I'm
actually writing them down,
but I'm too late for the Tele prompter,
so I'm going to have to go up their old school with a fucking pieces of paper up
there.
I know people can be like,
you feel good beach,
look over your shoulder dose.
There it is.
The teleprompter.
See that?
The rabbits already in the hat.
Um,
I never do these roads things either.
I never do them.
I thought a lot of those comedy central wants after awhile they just went off
the rails.
You know what I mean?
It just,
everything was like the fucking,
I dunno,
everything was so god damn.
Same,
same fucking stupid joke.
You know.
Hey,
I'm not
Shane,
this guy beat but doable.
But when he walked the walk because he woke up,
woke up a
nine 11,
you know,
whatever the fuck he could say that would
be the most,
you know,
air quote,
Edgy fucking thing,
even though it was totally fucking predictable.
Um,
so,
uh,
yeah,
I never got into those things,
you know.
Hey,
when you fuck your mother,
we did dogs get it at herpes when your fucking scurvy.
Um,
plus I don't get roasted.
Somebody you don't know,
like the most jokes I have for the people on this is for Lenny Clarke.
Cause I know Lenny and I love Lenny.
So I've got stories.
I know what he's done.
I got all this stuff I could shit on a,
I have more shit about Lenny Clarke than I do.
You know Greg Koski is a tough one too because everyone's going to Gog.
He's fucking stupid.
So I'm trying to think of another angle.
Um,
so really isn't one something about spike in a baby.
I have no idea.
Um,
so
okay,
I'm a,
I'm a little amped up for this thing.
A little nervous.
The laptop.
I can't fucking wait.
All I know is this is one of these deals where it's just like,
just fucking bring me up,
bring me up so I can do this thing and then I can relax.
Then I can relax.
It's all I need to do.
I just got to get through.
Just get through tonight,
tonight,
tonight.
Whoa.
Then it's easy.
Then there,
it's fucking easy.
I go back to my regularly scheduled standup dates,
you know,
God willing,
we'll get a third season of f is for family.
I've already been through that shit twice.
I'm right back into my comfort zone,
you know?
So I got here last night and um,
you know,
I it over to the fucking um,
laugh Boston cause everybody was going over to their,
run their row shit and I didn't want to do that.
I uh,
I just wanted to do stand up,
just go up there and be funny,
you know,
warm up,
loosen up a little bit.
And then tonight I'll just fucking do the jokes.
That is the game plan.
I'm going gonna have it printed out nice and fucking big.
The font is going to be nice and big,
so there's no way for me to fuck these things up.
And I'm just going to go right down the Deus.
I figure a,
there's like fucking,
we going to get,
we got Adam Ray,
we had,
we had fucking uh,
Susie soliloquy.
We got a Mikey monologue,
the story about,
uh,
like eight or nine fucking bad.
Do a minute on everybody.
I'm done.
But I got to do David the fucking longest.
So I got,
I got,
you know,
he's actually surprisingly not that hard to row and all the shit that he did.
You know you can,
you can get that guy pretty good.
Dry is difficult once you just get past,
you know,
he's just a little fella,
you know?
Then it's like,
well now what do I do now for Christ's sake?
Who's texting me now?
Huh.
Okay.
Anyways,
um,
yes.
And then once I get through that,
the rest of the year is downhill,
you know,
down fucking hill,
and I've already worked at,
I'm thinking if I get,
if we get a third season,
all right,
I'll get up early in the morning.
Okay.
Right.
Spent some time with my daughter and then uh,
I'll go over to the little fucking rehearsal place,
you know,
I'll do my little drum drum drum in there,
and then I go over,
I fucking write the shit,
then I'm home.
That's the game plan.
Then I get home,
take the daughter of walk around the block some point me and my wife pass each
other in the halls with like,
who are you again?
Oh,
that's right.
We're married and then that'll be my year.
So why give you a kiss after the loving
Inglebert?
Humperdink who fucking,
no.
Oh No.
Um,
who knew that that was going to be in my fucking head today?
I had no idea.
So anyways,
one of my new hobbies when I'm on the road is,
uh,
I watch Fox News and I watch CNN and I just flipped back and forth between them.
It is fucking fascinating.
Like,
I don't even know what those channels have become.
I don't know what they ever were,
but it is not news.
They're basically yelling at each other now
that's so fucking,
it's like,
it's like you're watching a sitcom,
you know?
All right,
here's,
here's the idea.
Here's the pitch for the show.
This does two news channels once conservative,
and this one's liberal.
I was watching that a Sean Hannity Guy and one of his stories was a story about
somebody on CNN.
You know,
though,
check what the,
uh,
the Mary Lou Retton haircut whenever her fucking name is the one who cried when
Trump got fucking elected,
which really was a low point in journalism.
Hilary lost,
she didn't get assassinated.
Jesus Christ even fucking what's his face held it together when he said,
JFK got killed.
It's a fucking,
Donald Trump gets elected.
You fucking sitting there blubbering for God's sakes,
woman,
get a hold of yourself.
So anyways,
uh,
okay.
Um,
he fucking was saying he's cast her picture up there and it says conspiracy
theory.
MMM.
Cause of whatever the fuck she said.
I don't,
I don't even know.
I'm just sitting there going like,
this fucking guy is doing a new story about a news person on another channel.
This is news.
When I was growing up,
like,
you know,
I,
Tom Brokaw was not doing stories about Sam Donaldson.
Okay.
You know when only white men gave the noobs no,
I'm kidding.
Um,
I have no idea.
I don't know you,
I just don't know what the fuck it is anymore,
but I got to tell you,
it's really entertaining.
You've got to do it.
People,
you got to step out of this fucking liberal conservative thing.
You've got to just step back and just enjoy it for what it is.
Um,
it is just a bunch of people who have just disappeared.
I don't there.
They all need like a fuck.
They all,
every one of them needs to take like two years off,
you know what I mean?
And I think they should send them all at first to separate places and then you
gradually get 'em reacclimated as human beings.
Right.
And he just kind of take,
sent them to like a camp.
Maybe they start playing a softball game,
but you know,
it's not Fox News for CNN.
You've got to mix up the players,
you know?
I mean,
it'll ruin the rivalry.
Like,
you know,
yeah.
When the NHL went to Russia to play the Russians and all those fucking,
you know,
the ranges were hanging out with the Bruins and the flyers were hanging,
it just,
people started getting drunk together.
Eh,
you know,
you're all right.
You know,
it kind of ruins it.
But,
um,
Fox News was going off,
you know,
that auto warm beer story,
that fucking horrific fucking story.
MMM.
You know,
everybody like judging the guy going,
boy,
Yo,
what the fuck he take fucking poster for?
Uh,
it's like anytime there's posters at my shows,
people always take him.
It's the end of the show.
It gives a fuck something you do,
you grab a little souvenir,
whatever.
I mean,
technically it's stealing,
but who gives a fuck?
I mean,
does that,
is that enough warranted to give guy 15 years hard labor.
He was there because of our foreign policy,
you know?
That's why they don't like that,
that we're this and they're that and we're fucking economic sanctions and all
that shit.
They don't like it.
MMM.
Like how I just said that to you guys.
Like that's actual news.
So Fox News was doing this thing where they were like,
they were going back and looking at shit that,
like some chick said on Huffington post and this Guy Larry Wilmore,
what the fuck he said,
but he first did,
he did a bit about like a,
you know,
call him the frat boy and like,
basically they didn't have any sympathy for the guy,
you know?
But now it plays out way weirder because the fucking Dick kid got killed over
there,
so they're sitting there,
you know,
the whole fucking thing was just fascinating to watch and like Fox News and she
was like,
these people are terrible bla bla bla that Dah Dah Dah.
You know,
and,
and just taking it kind of like at face value,
not taking into how was written,
why it was written.
I think everybody's fucked up in it to be honest with you.
I think it's fucked up to do that white privilege thing.
I understand it,
but the uh,
yeah,
I get that whole thing.
Well look what he deals with,
we deal with in this country.
It's something you can understand.
I am that which I get that point.
But uh,
I dunno when you take it to the point of having a little bit of joy about it,
which I probably would if I was on the other side because I am not a,
a,
a mature human being and I have anger issues.
I know that I would probably be coming at it like that too.
But it's,
it takes a lot to have empathy.
That's what I've learned.
You know what I mean?
Because as much as that chick on the Huffington post was making some good
points,
it's like,
well,
I don't see empathy on your side though,
and I'm not talking about towards white people.
It's like,
look at your fucking clothes.
As you're saying,
I'm complicit in your suffering.
What about the people that make you fucking clothes?
Yeah.
Okay,
I'll let sweatshop fucking labor.
Do you think about the five year old that sewed your fucking skirt together?
You don't give a fuck to you too busy focused on,
that's what human beings do.
We focus on our shit.
That's what I learned watching CNN all when I watched all these fucking white
guys.
I
say this about this other white guy.
They're all up in fucking arms,
the same fucking people,
the same kind of white people that when somebody black gets shot,
oh well I'll just see.
I'll just do what the police say.
You'll be fine.
Duh.
You know,
stop wearing hoodies.
they just,
then they just fucking get on with their lives.
Now all of a sudden they're fucking up in arms.
Yeah.
About this fucking dude.
You know?
But that's what people do though.
So I just kinda saw it.
Second,
you don't,
what you do is you insert yourself into the situation.
And if you see a white person and you're white,
you go,
oh my God,
that's terrible.
That could have been me.
I think,
you know,
maybe white people,
black people also need to be sent away.
You don't separate it at first,
then we all just,
you know,
kind of mix up and play softball to go.
Right.
But that doesn't work because look at that guy and the eagles.
He went to that country fucking concert and he starts dropping the n word.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't think these robots come and it's gonna be a bad thing.
Okay.
You know,
it'd be weird if good,
good.
Maybe there'll be like improved human beings.
Okay.
You know,
it'd be fucking weird is if they actually,
they made them so fucking life like that.
That'd be like fucking racist robot.
You know,
just walking him back.
Use paypal dot walk to work.
MMM.
A jury of your peers has fucking convicted,
you know,
actually if you just kind of,
I mean,
because the story's kind of like losing momentum,
but if you just watch it,
mmm.
And you just listened to people too.
They just see the world out there own fucking head and they just talk.
Uh,
I don't think they talk and you just fucking sit there and,
and join it.
Like
the people that fucking white dudes on Fox News are the widest.
They look like,
you know,
when they make those coming of age movies in the 80s and there'd be those
fucking a preppy frat boy guys.
Okay.
Like you looking at him going like,
dude,
I,
you do you seriously dress like that man?
I guess this is sort of fucking
judging them too,
but like,
there's one guy on there,
it's just like,
dude,
you look like the date rape is slash your girlfriend died during air quote rough
sex.
She was into it and it got carried away that this is what that guy looks like.
Um,
I dunno,
the whole fucking thing is just,
it's a weird thing,
but,
uh,
what I have learned is people,
the suffering they see is their own suffering and it's very hard to look at
other people's suffering and to try to,
you know,
take time out of your day to understand that regardless of what color you are.
I was kind of what I learned from that.
And,
and people who actually do are way beyond me.
And then beyond that,
people who then fucking try to do something about it,
you know,
like someone who would actually try to do something about sweatshop labor going
like,
all right,
well,
I'm only going to buy clothes that are in this country.
I tried to do that for a second.
And I did that like fucking 15 years ago when the options were ridiculous.
I was like,
I'm not wearing that out to a comedy club.
I'm going to get destroyed.
So I said to hell with these fucking kids who sewed together my shirts.
I was protecting myself when I was going down to the cellar because I didn't
want to get trashed.
Okay.
So I guess I'm saying I'm a selfish piece of shit.
I think that's what I learned.
Watch enough.
Fox and CNN.
I think I saw a lot of myself like these guys that just fucking into their own
dealer chicken,
the Huffington Post,
completely 100% into her own fucking deal.
You know
the whole fucking world.
Yeah.
The same way with those Fox News guys.
The entire world is the way she sees it.
Okay.
And those guys,
the entire world is the way that they see it and they just cannot fucking on any
other level fathom.
Any others,
any other reality
out there?
You know,
I think a lot of times I listened to feminist,
I just listened to what they say and I just switch around a couple pronouns
from,
from
men,
you know,
he to her.
Okay.
And it's just like you literally,
if I fucking took what you just said and I took out all the men,
I just replaced it with women in her and I swear to God you would sound like a
Trump supporter.
All right.
I'm off my fucking soapbox.
I was up there for a minute.
Now I'm off it.
What I'm really trying to say is you got to fucking watch Fox and CNN and pull
yourself out of it.
You know what I mean?
It's like your team got knocked out of the playoffs and you just sit there and
you just watch it.
Okay.
And just watching these fucking people like it's not,
none of it is news anymore.
It's just like a,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't know what it is.
It's,
it's their fucking opinions.
It's like two op ed channels.
It's like everybody's Andy Rooney,
except there's no humor in it anymore and they're just fucking,
I guess I'm doing that now.
My podcast,
like it's affected make built.
Where's,
where's,
where's the silly jokes?
You know what?
Maybe I'm out of jokes.
I don't have any fucking jokes left.
I so want to read you guys some of these fucking jokes.
I'm going to blame David Ortiz for childhood obesity.
There's one for you.
Oh,
the red sox.
Oh yeah.
I got some good shit for them.
Just to general.
Okay.
I don't have a lot of [inaudible] stuff.
Gronk House.
He's hard to cause.
I am going on last and I know everybody's going to be,
eh,
not saying this guy's dumb,
buttery pecan.
We'll go and any a walker and then I'd be like,
God,
fuck,
I can't do that joke.
Now what do I do?
MMM.
I Dunno.
I'll figure it out.
And worst case scenario,
I bomb and it's over in 10 minutes.
And then what do we do?
I just slowly walk out of the fucking room,
you know?
But I can't drink myself into a stupor,
Why?
Cause all Billie,
no fun
Billy.
No Fun.
That's right on and off.
Billy is what I really am.
Since I decided to be billing.
No Fun.
I've drank Saturday and Sunday,
both weekends and I have not drank Monday through Friday.
So,
um,
I'm not drinking tonight.
That'll be four days in a row.
I won't drink tomorrow.
And uh,
then I'll fly back Saturday.
I'm not going to drink that day.
I think I'll be good.
I've got to put a good two week fucking run together.
Maybe not quite as the following weekend.
I'm working with version.
Um,
who knows.
I don't know,
but I got it.
I got it dialed down though.
I got it back under control.
I like to think,
you know,
cause I said,
so I'm going to Billy.
Yay.
All right.
We're,
I'm going to give myself a chip.
Every five days I get a chip and then I get a drink.
That's how my Aa works,
you know?
Okay.
That's the problem with addicts.
It's just so all or nothing.
It's why they fucking miserable.
So,
so I need,
you just have like a glass of wine.
It just fucking relax.
All right.
You're gluttonous.
Psychopath.
I'm not a fan of addicts.
I'm really not.
Most,
some of them are cool,
but in general,
there's some of the most selfish fucking people you ever going to meet on,
on,
on the face of the fucking earth.
And they got that built in fucking excuse.
Uh,
it's not me.
It's the addiction.
So I love South Park.
They're like,
no,
no.
But,
but you did that.
You,
it's not me.
It's the disease,
the fuck out of here.
Every time it's disease.
It's never you just never you.
Um,
all right.
I think I've said enough stuff to offend people here that I get some fucking
emails.
All right,
let's uh,
let's read a little bit of advertising here.
Um,
yeah,
five,
four club,
uh,
looking good.
Doesn't need to cost a fortune because five,
four club is revolutionizing the way men shop at five folk club.
They found a way to make great looking clothes affordable for everyone.
Can I say the name of their fucking entity?
One more time.
Why wasted at the mall or wandering around in the stores?
Each month they send you a curated box.
It's one of the most overused fucking words ever.
Curated box.
You know,
like they seize fucking geniuses staring at sure.
Yeah.
Shirts,
Eh,
give him a couple of stripes in a fucking Polka dot.
You guys want to get some lunch?
I'm of two to three items that are hand picked to match the current season and
your style.
Five photo club partners with cutting edge designs and brands seal get the same
quality as top designers.
They've been helping men with fashion for over 15 years.
15 years.
I never fucking heard of these guys.
Where the hell you been doing it?
It's been a covert and to ship to over 100,000 men every month.
Chris Paul and Mark Walberg use five four club and five is featured in Gq,
vice and instyle among other publications.
They know what they're doing.
So if you don't,
that's so okay.
Cause Fivefold Club,
how many times can they say this has gotta be a record,
we'll help you build your wardrobe.
How many fucking times?
And they said the name and okay,
there's a title one,
two,
three did the two,
four,
five.
Okay.
Six,
seven,
eight,
nine.
This reed has nine fucking five folk clubs and now I just said that.
So that'll be 10 and as a member of five photo club,
you love some receive up to 50% off items in their online shop and access to
exclusive members only members only items like the jackets,
free shipping and size is size exchanges.
Okay,
go to five boat club.com now and enter the Promo Code [inaudible] and they'll
give you 50% off your first month's package plus a free pair of sunglasses.
That's 50% off your first package at five four club,
spelled Fiv fat.
F O,
U R foe club.com.
Promo Code [inaudible] club.com Promo Code Bird,
Jesus Christ.
Oh my goodness.
Here we go.
Lift everybody lift this CNN of ride shares.
Um,
that's why I look at it.
The other one that rhymes with mover,
they like the Fox News.
You know,
they don't give a fuck,
right?
If you're white,
get in the fucking car.
We don't give a shit what your priors are.
Lift.
It's like wait a minute,
have you done anything bad?
Cause if you did something bad,
that would really be be at,
if you were driving people around,
you know,
move her,
doesn't give a shit.
Right?
They don't give a fuck.
Okay.
All they need is white skin and a little bit of freckles and your fucking hard.
And that's a guy.
That's the truth.
I think they were actually Nazi hunters.
So looking into see who runs that fucking company.
I'm just saying all right,
but lift,
lift.
These are the nice people.
Live knows that their drivers,
your what keeps them moving.
So they do everything they can to make sure their drivers are happy on every
trip.
Lyft is to ride sharing company that believes in cheating.
Peep it's people.
Better lift believes that being a ride sharing drivers should be fun if you're
having a good time.
So the tasks and juries should I be,
I should be wearing sandals.
When I read this sitting fucking in the Lotus position,
lift was,
uh,
was the first to offer in APP tipping.
When you drive for Lyft,
Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers have been paid over 200 million and tips since the feature was
introduced and a 170 million of that was spent on yoga classes.
The restaurant Tofu express pay lets drivers get paid almost instantly instead
of waiting weeks.
Live has even taking the guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp device uses color coded coding to help passengers find their
drivers.
Uh,
you can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips,
want to earn more money,
drive more.
It's never been easier to give yourself a race.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers means happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect five star rating.
Go to lift.com/bird today and gear.
Yay.
And you get up $500 dot.
New driver bonus.
That's lift,
l,
Y,
F,
t,
Lima,
Yankee,
Fox Star,
Fox Trot,
tango.com/burr lyft.com/burr limited time only terms apply.
Um,
ah,
boto doe,
doe.
Brds Biondi.
Oh,
I can't do that.
I was,
uh,
why was going to say that?
Oh,
I can't do that one.
I thought about that kid and fucking Korea.
See,
this is the dangers of this.
You got to have that worked out.
All right,
let's start over again.
What's something a lot more safer?
Mandy's me undies laying here and dirty socks.
Doo,
Doo doot me undies.
Mandy's velvet up against my cook.
I love where to put those two fucking drawers on.
My name is bill.
It isn't one.
I don't know.
All right.
Elevate your underwear game to the next time,
to the next level with me undies.
You've perfected your wardrobe.
But what about this stuff?
Not everybody gets to see.
We're talking about your balls here and your Dick or you clamp,
whatever he got down there.
Maybe a hermaphrodite.
Maybe you have all three.
You know when it be nice if there was something nice and soft up against it of
your choosing.
I'm not talking about taking the subway during rush hour either.
All right.
If you've been settling for store bought underwear,
five packs,
I have something that will change your life for the better me undies.
I don't understand why you're settling for store bought underwear.
Like that's a difficult thing to fucking do.
I guess going to the mall can suck,
right?
Especially on black Friday.
Yeah.
What's the first thing you put on the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear.
Unless you,
Matthew mcconaughey make your most important piece of clothing the best it can
be with me undies.
What is me undies?
Oh,
just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your fucking deal with me on.
These are designed in La and made from sustainably sourced micro modal,
modal,
a fabric three times softer than cotton.
Cotton coffin,
cotton Biondi softer than soft.
Luxury underwear.
It comes in an ever changing selection of classic colors,
bold shades and adventurous patterns.
What do you get a tiger on your dick?
So you can trade,
tailor your undies to your own personal style.
And guess what?
You can save time and money each month with a monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready for inscription,
hey,
that's okay man.
He could still say,
that's because me undies is offering you 20% off their first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burn get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead,
revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr [inaudible] dot com slash bar you know
what the best rant about politics I've heard in awhile.
This fucking Jimmy Dore,
Jimmy Dore unlike me,
is actually informed.
And um,
he was calling somebody out on just fucking doing all these Trump jokes and was
just calling him like a corporate liberal.
Just acting as though all of this shit didn't exist during the Obama presidency.
All of these,
you know,
people upside down in houses,
these never ending fucking wars.
All of this shit.
Everybody gets all amped up about ties.
He says it way better than me.
Um,
okay.
I forget what,
what,
where he's on,
on the Internet,
but I'm considering moving my operation over there because youtube is a fucking
rip off.
Yeah,
there are a bunch of goddamn thieves.
MMM.
I told you the deal over there.
If,
if your video gets flagged,
then you don't get the advertising money yet.
They still play the ads.
So it's like,
well,
who gets the money then?
They try.
Oh no,
nobody gets it.
Really see it.
They get free ads.
So what's stopping the advertisers from flagging every video?
They bought time on that full of Shit.
MMM.
So I'm thinking of pulling my channel and putting it somewhere else.
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck to do.
Who knows?
All right.
Simply safe everybody.
You can rest easy when you protect your home and family with simply safe.
When you install your simply safe home security system,
you're arming your home with a powerful,
powerful sensors that tell you if a door opens or a window breaks.
It's a burglar's worst nightmare
is it?
I mean,
I think having like,
you know,
I was always thinking,
what if you had like one of the most poisonous snakes in the world,
right?
In the world world world,
right.
And then when you leave at night,
right before you leave,
you fucking,
you let the thing loose in your house.
I'm of course not really thinking this through of like eventually I have to come
home,
but because I never fantasize pass the person coming in,
you know,
and the guys like trying to Jimmy the lock in is,
is doing it.
That fucking Cobra comes up,
you know,
doing this little fucking,
dance right.
The snake,
you know,
just wait for that guy and the guy comes in,
he sneaks in and think it is just fucking bite some,
I have a black Mamba in there or some shit.
Okay.
Then you come home with like your fucking beekeeper suit on going here.
Sneaky.
Sneaky,
sneaky.
Or you know what?
You can do it.
You just get simply safe.
Okay?
That would be the worst nightmare.
You know what about a Komodo dragon and it just bite your leg and then just
follows around the house to you.
Fucking start.
Collapse starts eating your guts.
I mean that w I think that would be a worst nightmare,
but evidently simply safe is right up there with Comodo drift.
You can't afford a Komodo dragon or don't have a black Mamba guy.
Simply safe is what you want.
There's 105 decibel siren that alerts you at the first sign of trouble.
You'll have a dedicated team of security professionals watching over you.
You 24 seven ready to send the police.
What do you got,
Kevin Costner?
Is he going to carry me out as I nuzzle into the side of his neck was simply
there is no longterm contracts or hidden fees.
And around the clock monitoring is only 1,499 a month.
Call to action.
Set on.
Spend another night.
Second guessing your home safety gets simply safe and get some rest.
Go to simply say [inaudible] dot com I'm just picturing with 105 decibel alarm
goes up and you fucking shoot up in bed with an absolute panic going,
please let that be a squirreled.
It just bounced off my fucking window.
Um,
you don't want to eat.
And why doesn't everybody have a panic room?
Just sleep and that.
Fuck.
Then I'd be,
if my panic would be that the fucking door wouldn't open up and I'd be in there
in this fucking airtight,
well not air tight,
but soundproof fucking room.
Then he had some cheesy headline after I fucking died.
Right.
Panic room turns into actual panic room.
I'm sorry.
That's simply safe.
[inaudible] dot com for 10% off your order.
It's simply safe.com.
It's s,
I,
m p l,
safe.com.
Is there a reason why they always misspell the words of their company?
Is that because every website's taken at this point?
Yeah.
You know,
go to [inaudible] dot com B I.
L l E.
Bill Lee burb.
Um,
all right.
How much time have I done?
Yeah.
Oh,
37 minutes.
Well,
you know what?
Usually,
I'd give you a little more fucking freebies here,
but I've got to go back to writing,
which I really don't want to do.
Uh
Oh Jesus.
Well,
you know what,
I guess,
I guess that's what I gotta do here.
Uh,
I,
yeah,
I got to sit down and get through this fucking rough sting.
I need more shit on Podria.
I need more shit on Gronk.
I mean,
where do you go?
Where do you go with either one of them?
I get it.
He's little and he's dumb.
What else is there?
What the fuck else is there?
Um,
all right.
That's the podcast for,
I was just checking it.
I'm just,
you know,
trying to get you home.
Okay.
Now you can listen to some music and uh,
then we'll have,
uh,
some greatest hits from a podcast gone by from,
to Thursday,
from years ago.
I have no idea what Andrew Sam was,
who's gonna fucking pull,
but he always pulls up some good shit.
I want to thank everybody who said that they had enjoyed listening to mute math.
M.
U.
T e math,
mute math,
all one word.
They have a new album,
you gotta check 'em out.
You got to see him live.
You got to tell your friends are bottom.
So you can be the cool person that told them that there's a band called mute
math that that exists,
right?
I'm telling you as great as your album,
Zahra,
never even fucking better live.
Go check them out if you get a chance.
All right,
that's the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Have a great weekend.
You can't sell it.
You know how the race goes on Monday.
All right.
See you.
I'm hoping not to see.
Hold on.
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 22nd,
2009.
And uh,
I'm going to start this podcast by apologizing for not doing a pod,
not only not doing a podcast last week,
but not even giving you guys the decency of sending out a bulletin with some
sort of an explanation.
Um,
I dunno,
I'm in New York right now and uh,
I'm working on this movie thing and it's been raining and it's been a really,
it's rained like every fucking day.
And it's really been affecting the way the whole shoot things going.
So uh,
you know I had a lot of nights where I was walking in at about six in the
morning and uh,
yeah it was that.
And then also not to mention my flight didn't have batteries for my fucking
recorder.
You know what other excuse do I have?
Oh I also did a podcast for 25 minutes last Monday and realized that I didn't
even have the fucking recorder on the dumb fuck that I am.
Yes son fuck head daddy is.
Um Yeah so I didn't even have the goddamn thing on and I was meaning to buy
batteries and I never did.
And basically I am Douche bag of the week.
How do you like dad?
I'm Douche bag of the week for not cause I didn't do a podcast.
You know we all miss days at work.
Hell a rod miss two days in a row because he was a little fatigued.
Hey Jay was a little fatigued.
You know you make 200 fucking million dollars.
You missed the first two months of the season cause you hips fucked up.
Cause,
I dunno what,
you fucking stuck the needle in too far,
you know.
Oh Jesus.
That was a cheap shot.
I'll tell you guys right now.
Um,
as far as baseball goes,
um,
I'm already getting,
I'm getting into golf and uh,
I'm preparing myself.
If one more fucking guy that I loved test positive for steroids,
there's one dude in particular.
If,
if he,
if they ever named his name,
I am done with fucking baseball.
I'm not gonna say who it is that a respect.
Most of you can probably guess who,
but uh,
I'm going to be done with the sport,
so this is what I figure.
I figure basketball and hockey go,
you know,
they go all the way into like the second week of June.
So then all I got to do is I just got to kill the last two weeks of June and the
fucking in the four weeks of July,
that's all I have to kill.
And then,
then it's going to be pre season.
Even then they got the hall of fame game,
right?
They got the hall of fame game.
I think that's one is in July.
And then I'm good and I don't have to deal with baseball anymore because I
can't,
I can't fucking take it anymore,
you know?
And believe me,
I don't believe in Santa Clause.
I'm not like a fucking idiot.
But you know,
Sammy Sosa test positive.
What do you think about Sammy Sosa?
I mean,
I think Barry bonds belongs in the hall of fame because of what the fuck he did
before he became this roided out monster.
I mean,
the guy was,
he was always a beast.
Then he turned into the hulk.
You know what I mean?
So I mean,
whatever tea you say,
he's better than Babe Ruth.
I wouldn't say that because Babe Ruth,
you know,
wasn't on juice.
But why wasn't Babe Ruth on juice?
You know why?
Because they didn't have any juice back then.
That guy was on the fucking sauce and he was eating fried chicken and he was
date rape and checks on a fucking train on the way down to Baltimore.
That's what I read.
You know,
he's in the hall of fame.
So why not Barry bonds and his huge fucking HGH head?
Why can't he get in?
But Sammy Sosa,
this is why I say no to that guy because that mother fucker was he,
he wasn't anybody.
And then all of a sudden he was somebody and then he was gone again.
And not only did he do roids,
he got caught with a fucking corked bat.
Okay,
what the fuck else do you need?
You know,
what else do you fucking need at that point?
Have your best friend fucking get on the mountain under hand the ball to you.
And that guy hit,
he had like,
what?
606 home runs?
I think he hit like fucking 560 of them in a year and a half.
Baseball's been Betty,
Betty Good to me.
Ah,
shut up.
Stupid.
You're going to needle sticking out of your shirt pocket.
Um,
yeah.
So I think I'm going to be,
I'm going to be done.
I'm going to be done with baseball and be fucking,
I mean he'd done with it.
One More fucking guy that I love.
Test positive,
you know,
cause you know what you do.
I don't know about you guys,
but I go back to to when I was chairing the player on and getting all excited
and you just feel fucking stupid.
You know,
I remember in 1998 who the fuck was watching baseball.
Baseball was finished.
They still hadn't recovered from the strike.
The only thing that was good that was going on was cal Ripken broke Lou Gehrig
streak and then all of a sudden McGuire and Sosa having this home run fucking
contest.
And I sat there like some depression.
Eric fucking kid,
boy,
oh boy,
garlic GED.
Just see that one go over the fence.
I fucking scalped a ticket to go watch Mark McGuire hit his 28th home run
against the San Diego Padres as they say up in Boston.
I'm
fucking,
I I,
you know,
sat in the upper deck and left field.
I watched him take batting practice was actually pretty funny cause at that
point he was such a fucking rock star cause he had already come close to you
before.
This dude was such a fucking rockstar that half the stadium was full.
Just to watch him.
We was was just to watch this guy take batting practice and he came up to the
plate and he got a standing ovation like an hour before the game.
So everybody's waiting for him to fucking crush,
went over the wall.
And I'll never forget this.
They pitched the first practice pitch in and he laid down a bunt and everybody
laughed and some idiots booed because,
uh,
cause they're morons.
You know,
those are the same people who would just standing back then they were just
standing around cause there was no youtube that they could sit there and fucking
write their dumb ass comments on.
So anyways,
Jesus Christ,
you know what,
if you're not into sport,
should definitely not listen to this fucking podcast.
Uh,
I got to have a couple of congratulations out there.
I gotta congratulate the fucking Los Angeles Lakers.
Jesus Christ.
I've got to admit,
I did not watch one second of the celebration,
I a or the last game.
I just was sort of flipping him once I saw they were like up by 15.
I was like,
God,
those motherfuckers.
And then,
uh,
you know,
and then ESPN comes on and says that they have 15 championships and only two
behind the Celtics and a,
which is true.
But I also know every moron,
La Laker fan thinks that the Los Angeles Lakers have 15 titles when they don't,
they have fucking tent.
Okay.
And I believe that the fucking titles belonged to the fans.
What the fuck did the people in Minnesota celebrate?
Nothing.
Those aren't,
there's,
Oh God,
I'm in such a country fucking mood.
I just got,
I got to do this podcast though because I know I'm going to sleep till fucking
one tomorrow.
My,
my whole fucking sleep pattern is just out of whack.
Um,
so anyways,
if you knew what of my podcast,
I do one of these mother fuckers every week unless,
uh,
unless some fucking staying out until six in the morning and it's raining every
night.
So,
um,
let's get on with the questions here.
The question for the week.
All right,
this person says,
Bill,
I recently read something online about Michael Vick negotiating a spokesman deal
for Peter.
Since you now have your dog,
how fucking stupid is that?
You know,
like anybody's going to believe that Michael Vick gives a shit about dogs.
That's like when,
when like,
like Vince Neil fucking gets busted for drinking and driving and somebody dies
in the car and then like three weeks later he's like,
hey,
this is Vince Neil.
You know,
when you're out partying it up,
just make sure you got a designated driver.
You know,
I never understood that.
It's like,
dude,
where the fuck do you get off telling me what the fuck I should do before I get
behind the fucking wheel?
Huh?
You fucking cunt.
Um,
you know what I mean?
So Michael Vick is going to be a spokesman.
I don't understand people at Peta.
What are they trying to just embarrass the guy?
Is that what they're doing?
Like,
yeah,
listen,
we got so much power.
We're going to make this guy come on TV and act like he gives a shit about dogs
when he clearly doesn't.
That doesn't make any fucking sense when you really think about it.
Right.
That's like a,
that'd be like as some woman's group having a convicted rapist go on and be
like,
you know,
you re you really got to respect these broads.
They uh,
you know,
they work hard.
They,
uh,
they'll,
they'll make you a sandwich and a,
sorry,
I'm riffing.
Um,
that was supposed to be the rapist saying to the ladies going,
sorry,
I'm riffing.
And the ladies were supposed to be yelling.
There's nothing about making a sandwich in that statement,
you know,
if you didn't get it,
I'm really not good at that type of shit.
All right,
let's,
let's plow to this question.
Um,
all right,
so we're going to have terrorist fucking give a 4th of July tips in the next
couple of weeks.
Oh my God.
I was really,
I was literally ready to go into some hacky fucking Middle Eastern accent,
which is really some,
just me imitating somebody else doing an Indian accent,
somebody from India,
you know,
make sure your daughter put far Craig.
I was literally going to do that and I stopped myself because just out of
fucking respect for myself and you guys as the listeners.
Okay.
I swear to God,
if I actually did that,
like,
and you guys actually came back next week and listen to the podcast,
you know,
I would lose all respect for you.
All right,
let's finish this question.
All right.
I recently read something about a online,
about Michael Vick,
a negotiating a spokesman deal for Peter.
Uh,
since you now have your dog,
uh,
what do you think about this?
I think I just answered that.
I personally hate the fucker since it's people like him that would leave a dog
by,
by the bridge or worse after they'd done fighting them.
Not to mention this is just a ploy to get back on the public's good side so he
can work his way into playing football again.
Also,
since you're now doing the podcast,
uh,
wait,
let me just address that point.
You know,
so he can,
uh,
it's just a ploy so he can get back in pub on the public's good side so he can
play football again.
Let me ask all you animal lovers out there.
Don't you think Michael has paid his debt to society?
I mean,
what the fuck else does this guy have to do?
His dream was to play professional football.
It got taken away.
He had millions of dollars.
He's fucking,
he has nothing left.
They took his house,
they took his mom's house.
The guy did time for fucking with dogs.
He went to Leavenworth,
Leavenworth,
Sammy the bull didn't go to fucking Leavenworth.
He went right.
I'm just,
I just literally just said that.
I have no idea if he went there,
and that's one of those bar room fucking things you,
that's something you say in a bar where no one can fucking do the research.
I guess they can now in their blackberries,
you know?
But you guys are all at your computers.
I'm sure everybody's clicking and you're fucking keyboards.
But you know what I mean?
The guy went to fucking Leavenworth.
He was the quarterback of the Atlanta Falcons.
He was one of the,
he was on his way.
They were talking like acting like he was the Michael Next Michael Jordan.
But he's playing fucking football.
Right.
And what does he do?
He has some dog fights.
People flip the fuck out.
Right.
I'm not saying what he did,
what he did wasn't fucking,
it was bizarre.
What he did was fucking bizarre.
Cause I,
I,
I don't know that I had heard a dog fights,
but I just thought that was so like some,
uh,
gangs in New York.
Shit,
I didn't know people still did that stuff.
But anyways,
I mean he lost everything.
The guy lost everything.
He lost two fucking years of playing.
He,
the guy lost everything and he went to fucking Leavenworth.
Yeah.
Jesus fucking Christ it,
you know,
fuck you peed off.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm not doing your Goddamn fucking announcement.
All right.
I spent the last two years try not to get raped.
I lost all my fucking money.
I lost my fucking career and I'm probably gonna sign with the fucking Detroit
lions.
Isn't that enough for you cunt?
You fucking Weirdos.
Why don't you go yell at Obama for fucking slap in a house?
Fly like you've never done that.
Can you fucking believe Obama got shit for it's a fucking house with lands on
Shit.
Get it off me.
You know.
How about a mosquito where the would people at Peta flip out about a fucking
mosquito,
you know,
don't those things carry diseases?
You dumb fuck off.
Speaking of that swine Flus back,
Huh?
Good ole swine flu.
You've got to love swine flu as long as you don't get it and nobody loves gets
it.
I'm telling you this,
you know there's good things,
you know,
thin out the traffic,
let's get some,
how the fuck did swap,
I was doing a bit about that and maybe I can bring that back about how anytime a
new disease comes out,
like it can't just be like,
okay,
you know,
someone was in the forest and they got bit by something.
It always has to be somebody fucked an animal,
you know,
aids.
Some dude,
somebody fucked a monkey,
you know,
they fucked her monkey and then they got on the Concorde and they blew a
stewardess and a or a male stewardess and then there was aids.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I'm telling you yellow fever,
dude,
somebody fucked the fucking cow,
dude.
Really,
really swine flu.
I'm telling you,
dude,
down in Mexico,
they fucking,
if they fuck pigs down there,
you know,
don't see anybody fucking picks up here to you.
Shut up.
Everybody comes a goddamn doctor.
Um,
I don't know.
Where do diseases come from?
I think they actually,
uh,
I dunno,
I was actually gonna say it.
He'd done,
do you think that there would be fucking,
I think they would be,
but would you think this,
would you think that they would be evil enough?
Sorry,
I was just making sure there's fucking thanks recording because this happened to
me last week and I talked for 25 minutes and it didn't,
do you think that they would actually be fucking evil enough to actually just
create a disease?
You know,
I do.
And then actually think that they could somehow control it and um,
I dunno man.
Do you got something has to be done.
There's just too many fucking people.
Yeah.
I've said this before.
I swear to God,
I'm 41 I don't have any kids.
I really think I should be getting a tax break for not adding to the traffic.
You know,
I think everybody should be required to wait until their forties to have kids.
Let some old people die.
Let some accidents happen,
you know,
let some fucking people die so we don't have to fucking have 19 lane highways.
You know,
maybe it's good that people are fucking pigs.
I don't know if in the end of it,
some people fucking die and then they don't have eight kids and ma'am,
you know,
does anything I say makes sense.
It's just so fucking stupid sometimes.
So anyways,
let me finish with this question here.
Um,
also since you're now doing the podcast and your new microphone system,
well,
we get a chance to hear any more of you on the road or in an airport.
I found those to be hilarious and like the sound better.
Don't know why the new ones are too quiet.
Uh,
but still free.
So I probably shouldn't be complaining.
Hope to see you on stage soon dude.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the deal is with that.
Maybe I,
I think,
uh,
last weeks was too quiet because I had a problem.
I didn't adjust the device correctly.
I'm on the road,
I don't have the microphone and uh,
you know,
I'm on the talent end here.
I'm not on the fucking,
I'm not the guy in the studio.
I'm not Bob Rock here.
Okay.
So sometimes there might be a little fucked up,
but um,
yeah,
I know a lot of people like those old podcasts where I used to just go off on
people in airports.
Um,
I dunno.
I guess I could do it,
but it was always easier to do it on my phone cause people,
they had no idea I was talking to them.
But if I sit here with this fucking device,
you know,
God knows somebody who will take some nine 11 statute and I'll be in some
goddamn back room.
Um,
all right,
let's get to overrated.
Underrated.
Okay.
Overrated.
Underrated for this week.
All right.
Overrated people who make those,
uh,
that moves me.
Emotional grunts during public performances.
Uh,
Jesus isn't that yet.
Then that the fucking truth,
if you're listening to a firsthand story about saving a person's life perhaps,
but making a noise across between almond lighting.
I'm enlightened and I have a stomach pain in response to a trivial fact gets old
quick.
Yeah,
I absolutely have to fucking agree with that one.
Another one,
overrated.
This is one that's going to fucking definitely get some feedback.
Somebody says public school teachers are overrated.
They only work nine months a year.
Get paid living wages with full Ben benefits and pensions and they have a
ridiculously easy job.
I'm going to pause.
There was all the,
any,
if I have any teachers who are listening,
they're just teaching the same shit over and over again every year and they for
the most part suck at it.
Wow.
Calculus aside,
most of the shit is really simple.
Like how hard is it to teach kids how to spell the word tree every year.
It's not like the Boston tea party gains a new level of nuance every year.
You teach it yet they complain,
we're underpaid,
we're underappreciated.
But Shit,
you're overpaid for working a semi part time job that you mostly suck at.
You're given a free pass to the middle of class and somehow the bonus of a
social martyrdom.
I know,
I didn't say that right.
People are always bitching.
Oh,
we need more teachers,
Dude,
our school teachers middleclass what do you,
what do you consider middleclass 25 grand a year.
Whatever the fuck they pay.
Um,
those poor things.
Living off of government money and having to explain really simple shit to
children.
Not An easy job like working with minimum wage,
hauling debris,
working the fields are cleaning bathrooms in convalescent homes.
Stupid fucking lazy coal miners.
They don't contribute to society like we do.
I guess this is the teacher's talking.
We hope we help mold young minds.
Great job.
That's why most people are fucking morons.
All right.
All right dude.
You know I'm,
I'm,
I'm going to fucking way on in this one.
I think what you're doing is you're blaming the ass of the problem.
All right.
Do it.
Would you want to stand there in front of 30 snot nose kids,
18 of which probably have to dump fuck,
who didn't wear a fucking condom for parents,
you know,
and you got to get there with their fucking Brat kid and all these fucking
parents,
no parent today can admit that their kid is a Douche bag,
you know,
not overall.
No parent would admit that.
But you know what I mean?
Like in a certain situation,
they always got a fucking excuse.
They got add.
The teachers,
uh,
was doing this so they were doing that,
you know,
I do.
Do you want to be a fucking thing?
It's such a fucking great job,
dude.
You go be a God damn teacher.
I know what you mean,
dude.
Nine months a year is the shit and you get the whole,
like their vacation days are ridiculous.
That is a great point.
Think about that.
They get all those Jewish holidays off.
They get the PTA thing off,
they get the fucking Thanksgiving week off.
They get like a 10 day vacation,
14 days vacation over Christmas,
February vacation,
April vacation and summer vacation.
You know,
and you do come in from nine to three.
And I got to admit,
even if you are teaching calculus,
once you do it for a number of years,
you got it down.
But you know what,
you can say that about everybody.
You know
the fuck.
Let me tell you know,
how many basements do you have to refinish before you got it down?
Well,
you know what you gotta do,
you know,
I dunno.
And I,
I think,
uh,
and,
and anytime we get into shit,
the first thing they cut is they always cut education.
They always kind of education and can people have old fucking books.
I Dunno,
you know,
something,
I talked to some of the people here in New York and some of the shit that they
got to deal with and some of the public schools,
you know,
and no matter what they do,
the kids never fucking wrong,
blah,
blah.
Um,
I will,
I'll tell you this,
I do totally agree with their hours are ridiculous and the amount of vacation
time that they get is ridiculous.
But I gotta be honest with you,
dude,
think about flying,
getting on an airplane and there's a fucking screaming kid.
All right,
now multiply that times 30 and you've got to spend six fucking hours.
At least when you're on the God damn plane,
you can ignore the kid,
you can put on a Walkman.
You can't do that as a teacher.
You got to actually somehow get these kids to shut the fuck up and then teach
them how to spell the word tree,
you know?
Fuck that.
You can have that job.
Um,
all right.
I actually thought about being a teacher for a while before I did stand up.
You know,
I just wanted to somehow being in front of a group of people and be funny and I
remember every job I thought about Ibi be funny,
I'll be a cop,
but I'll be a funny cup.
I'll pull people over and I'll let him go.
You know?
That's what I used to think.
You know,
I'd be one of those guys who gets shocked during the second fucking week cause
I'm trying to make friends,
you know,
with my authentic need to be liked.
All right,
let's get into the bad press thing.
A few weeks ago I mentioned how,
um,
you know,
there's certain groups of people that just always get good press.
You know,
firemen always get good press.
The uh,
the men and women in the armed services always get good press and blob.
And for the most part,
99% of it is right.
All right.
But if you saw Jurassic Park and you listen to Jeff Goldbloom explained chaos
theory,
there's exceptions,
you know,
there's no way,
there's not one douche bag in the navy.
There's no way.
There's not one asshole at the fire department.
You know,
there are.
So I wanted to hear the stories and here's one.
Bill is about an army guy.
Bill,
I have a story about an old neighbor of mine who was in the army.
Most people in the army never seem to have anything negative said about them.
But that's not the case with me.
I used to live next to a family in which there were six sons and each of them
were real pieces of shit.
That's hilarious.
Isn't there always just that fucking piece of shit?
Scumbag family,
you know,
every fucking one of them is a Pete.
The Dad's a piece of shit.
The mother's a piece of shit.
All the sons,
all the daughters that dog their car that it's just a from head from top to
bottom.
It's just a piece of Shit fucking family.
Right.
And they all sit there breathing through their mouth.
All right.
Anyways,
um,
so he goes,
yeah,
they're all pieces of shit.
He goes,
I'm talking about the types of assholes who would drop a hit of acid in
someone's beer and get a kick out of watching the person trip his ass off.
Every one of them was arrested at least once.
The oldest was the biggest piece of shit out of the bunch.
He shot a liquor store clerk and I think he paralyzed the guy from the waist
down.
But out of all of them,
there was one who considered himself to be the price.
Why you ask?
Because he was the one who was in the army and whenever this guy would come back
home to visit,
he would bring in quotes,
army toys with him.
Ah,
this
is a great fucking story.
Um,
there are a few stories that I remember.
One time he had a smokescreen and set it off in a neighbor's yard.
Uh,
there were,
there were these blue flames shooting out the back and just burning up the
grass.
And in a matter of five seconds you couldn't see any of the houses on the
street.
Another time he set off a flare in the middle of the night,
I can still see him setting the thing off.
He just smacked the end of it on the pavement.
Out came this little ball of light that shot up in the sky and then poof,
it was daylight out.
He woke up half the neighborhood.
Uh,
but the worst ever was when he was home for Thanksgiving.
And I saw him out at a bar.
He had brought home a fucking hand grenade and was trying to sell the fucking
thing.
One last thing about this family.
They had a retarded brother who was a fucking monster,
like 250 pounds.
All I did with this brother was basically keep them locked up in a room and let
them watch pro wrestling one year at the 4th of July block party.
They thought it would be funny to get them drunk and let them loose at the
party.
That was easily in the top three scariest moments of my life.
No bullshit.
People are hopping fences and fair.
This guy,
he didn't hurt anyone,
but he dent the shit out of the tool shit.
See what I'm saying?
Yeah.
That's where there's always one asshole.
I don't give a shit.
I don't give a shit is always going to be the,
he's trying to sell a fucking hand grenade.
I got a question for you guys.
Would you buy it?
I wouldn't.
I'd be so afraid.
I blow my fucking hand off.
But if someone bought it,
I would.
Yeah.
I want to be in the vicinity and in the opposite direction of where they threw
it.
I just want to be,
are there any,
uh,
any military people listen to this podcast?
Is there anything that you can,
uh,
how big is that?
It's like a hand grenade.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like if someone,
like I'm,
I'm in a hotel room,
right?
If somebody threw a hand grenade in this fucking room,
And it was on the other side of my bed and I jumped on this side of the bed,
like fucking Tom Cruise and one of those mission impossible fucking movies,
you know,
in the movie I live,
what happens to me in real life?
You know,
what happens?
Do I what?
I immediately lose my hearing,
which shrapnel go through the bed with me in the bed.
Just go flying out the fucking window.
What I be all right,
will I stop asking questions?
All right,
let's move on.
Here's another one,
a bill.
Uh,
congrats on the tonight show and the movie.
Thank you.
And even more so on the dog.
I got a pair of,
let me read this.
This is one I should have enlarged.
I got a pair of pound Mutts,
uh,
mutts two years ago and it changed my fucking life.
The whole thing you said about not even knowing them a month ago and now already
dreading the day they're going to die.
Fuck,
I'm right there with you.
Dogs are kids who never disappoint.
Even when my girl ate my cell phone,
I loved her.
You mean like your girl dog?
I actually thought you meant your daughter.
That's fucking some idiot.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
he said I still loved her.
I never knew I had it in me.
Um,
yeah,
man,
I gotta I gotta fucking agree with you dude.
Fucking dogs are the greatest goddamn things ever and I respect cat people,
but I,
I just,
I don't get it.
Cats are like the hot chick at a bar,
man.
They just fucking,
they come to you when they need you and then they just,
I,
I respect cats.
I totally respect cats because,
uh,
they're like loaners,
you know,
every once in a while they pop in,
hey,
what's going on?
You know,
how you been?
All right,
take it easy.
Then they leave.
I totally get that shit.
But like,
um,
I don't know,
just the way they kind of come and go and they don't pay rent.
This is an arrogance to that,
you know,
I think dogs are a lot more appreciative,
you know?
I think they sense,
I think dogs have a bigger sense of the monetary system than cats too.
And plus cats practice killing you.
I don't like that fucking girlfriend.
I had years back,
I,
you know,
I just,
I would just send something watching me.
I turned around and I catch the cat,
like stalking me.
It was annoying.
It was annoying that the thing little thing thought it was going to fucking do.
So,
I mean,
it could do something to me.
All right,
so I don't need all you cat people to be like,
dude,
let me tell you something.
Dead Dick wanted to,
you know,
if I want it to,
if I wanted to,
I could take out one of the many weapons that human beings have invented where I
could fucking kill a cat from across the room.
I got to tell you right now,
if Michael Vick was fighting cats,
he,
he would have got community service.
People just don't give a shit about cats,
you know?
But people love,
they love dogs.
You can trash Katz.
I am telling you,
you can be in a comedy doing standup comedy and you can fucking trash cats and
people just don't give a shit.
But you start trashing dogs and people really,
they really have a problem with it.
You know,
cats,
the gross,
they shit in the house.
It's why,
why can't you just go outside and do that?
You know?
Ugh.
Is it ever is the litter box everclean is there any guy out there you dating the
girl with the fucking cat and the stupid fucking things.
They have no boundaries.
They jump up on tables there on the bed.
They were on your chest.
There are fucking on the couch.
You're an animal.
Get on the God damn floor.
If I had a cat,
I can't even begin to tell you how much I would fucking torture it.
You know?
I would get one of those little spray bottles with the water.
I guess that's what you're supposed to use to keep them off the couch.
I would just do that all the time.
Just in general.
Shoot him right in the fucking face.
That's what I would do.
You know.
Fuck a fucking civil rights rally.
God Damn firehose right to the face.
I'm all right.
You don't know how to bring that up.
All right.
Um,
cash registered.
Hey Bill,
did you see the Lakers?
Uh,
take the championship 99,
86.
It was awesome.
Yes,
I did a,
Phil Jackson now has his record,
10th championship ring on his finger and you really look like a Leprechaun next
to Conan.
Every time I do Kona somebody tells me that you look like as gay little brother,
but Baba Baba Ba uh,
he's pretty tall.
He's six,
four,
I think he's actually like six foot six.
Um,
anyways,
also I was thinking about your position against self checkout lines.
Um,
I was at the store the other day and saw there were only two people working at
registers and the other eight were self checkout lines.
It was appalling.
And half the time a person,
the self checkout,
something malfunctions and someone has to come over to help.
So why the fuck don't they just put a competent,
efficient individual at the register?
That's just another example of our increasing unemployment rate.
I totally agree with you.
People are fucking morons.
You want to see classic example of fucking morons.
We're all those idiot standing in line to buy the new iPhone.
People have like the memory of like two minutes now.
And when the first iPhone came out,
what happened?
Everybody ran out and they bought the fucking thing.
They stood in line like they were going to go see Bruce Springsteen backstage or
some shit.
They get the phone,
the phone sucked,
the service sucked,
everything sucked.
It was overpriced.
They recalled something and then two months later they fixed it,
right?
And then the second wave,
we're better phones for like $200 cheaper.
So why the fuck when the next phone comes out?
Would you run in line to buy the first one again?
You know why?
Cause you're a dumb fuck.
That's why.
And you had the same dumb fuck who goes into a supermarket and uses one of those
automated cashier lines.
Cause you think it's easier.
You think it's quicker and you think it's better.
You're a moron.
You're working for free for the supermarkets and you help them put people out of
jobs.
You big fucking,
a month ago,
two people did the job for you for free.
He just stood there with your hands in your pockets.
It's
whatever,
dude.
You know what?
Uh,
you're,
you're fighting a losing battle.
People are morons.
And if he come out with some shiny new shit,
the lineup to go do it.
I don't give a fuck what it is.
All right,
there's my little fucking editorial for the week.
All right?
Uh,
sports knowing things in sports,
Pau Gasol,
his fucking face.
Come on Laker Fan.
Gee,
you got to admit it,
right?
You won the championship.
You're in a good mood.
You got to admit,
come on.
If that guy wasn't fucking playing for you,
that vice head,
oh,
that itchy beard.
Gee,
it's like,
is he doing like,
what was that show?
He had the queer eye for the straight guy.
That's what he needs.
He needs like a makeover,
you know,
I think he just realizes that he's weird looking and he's trying to cover it up
with hair.
Um,
all right.
You know,
one of these days I'm going to run into that guy and he's going to take his size
fucking 19 sneaker and he's going to stop me right in the face anyways,
over,
uh,
over time this guy gets filed or commits a foul.
Every time he gets a follow commits,
a foul,
he acts like somebody committed a crime.
I know I've been doing an impression of him on stage and a any podcast
listeners,
if you come out to one of my shows,
uh,
if anytime you want to yell that out,
please do it in between jokes.
I would really appreciate that.
Don't do that during a joke.
Um,
that moment during my set when I look lost and I act like I'm thirsty,
taking a sip of water,
but I'm really trying to think about what the fuck I'm going to talk next.
Yell it out then.
And as an added bonus,
I'll do Derick cheater impression.
My Derek Jeter impression is,
uh,
the impression of Derek.
A impression of Derek Jeter taking a fast ball right down the middle of the
plate.
Uh,
for strike one.
I do what I do.
You know,
I do a fantastic impression of what he does anyways.
Uh,
ps,
what do you think of the Stanley Cup game seven.
I thought it was an amazing game.
Grateful hockey and surprising the wings choked.
Thanks again for the podcast.
Do the wings didn't choke.
You know,
that's the new age of sports.
If somebody wins,
that means the other person choked.
They didn't choke.
They just weren't,
the penguins were a better fucking team,
you know.
Um,
I dunno,
that was a,
that was a great,
that was a great series.
Um,
I liked it and I was psyched.
I had mixed emotions.
I didn't want to see Detroit when,
again,
just out of jealousy.
But,
um,
I'm still bummed the Steelers won the Superbowl,
you know,
fucking patriots caught right up to them.
We were one behind them and now somehow were three behind them again.
But,
uh,
you know,
I don't know,
but I respect the Steelers.
I mean,
they're always beating powerhouses for their titles now,
like the Seattle Seahawks and the Arizona cardinals.
And uh,
you know,
who knows,
maybe next year they'll play the saints for the biggest trophy in pro football.
Oh,
I have no right to be bitter.
I just want to see the Bruins win a Stanley Cup and then I'm done.
And then obviously,
you know,
hey,
is another,
this,
another way I'm going to get out of fucking a,
I'm going to get out of watching baseball when the rest of my heroes fucking
test positive is a Wimbleton.
Wimbleton tennis starts,
uh,
starts this week,
that'll kill another weeks.
And then all I gotta do is just worry about July.
And at that point there's gotta be some arena football.
What do you football fans who just refuse to watch baseball.
What do you do during July?
Maybe I could get out of the house and actually work out,
you know,
take up sailing.
All right.
This is the end of the podcast.
This one is a,
this one's kind of short this week,
but it's late at night.
And,
um,
I dunno if it rains tomorrow.
I'm going to ended up shooting,
I believe,
have no idea.
It's very up in the air,
so I probably should get some sleep.
Um,
even though they really don't call us until five.
What can else,
can I talk,
I don't know what else to fucking talk about.
Oh,
I added a date that I do not have up on my website yet.
Uh,
hopefully I'll have it up by the time I post this.
Um,
I am doing another Monday,
only show at the punchline in a San Francisco.
Um,
I did one back in March.
I did two shows and I just went up and I just sorta told stories while I kind of
did my act.
And,
um,
I had probably two of the best sets I can ever remember having.
So I'm sure this time,
uh,
I don't know.
I know I'm going to have a good time again.
I just always have a good time when I'm up there and,
uh,
I dunno.
That's it.
That's the end of the fucking podcast.
I'm getting loopy here.
I actually,
you know what I've been doing during the day,
they got to,
I found another studio here in New York work and go play fucking drums.
And I'm telling you I'm inching closer and closer to being able to play that
good times,
bad times.
If I just fucking play drums,
I swear to God I would've had it down by now.
But I always go like all these days in between fucking drumming and shit.
But I'm telling you and when I get that thing down without a doubt,
I'm going to fucking make a video of it and you guys can all trash me about what
a Douche bag I looked like,
but I'm still going to be able to play it.
And uh,
my foot is that,
you know what I'm talking about this shit right now.
Cause I know most people don't give a fuck.
It's my foot is actually is,
is,
is aching right now for the amount I played for like two fucking hours
and I was just working on this,
uh,
that Joe,
Joe Mayor,
that fucking heel toe thing.
I'm going to get that thing down.
I'm getting that down and I'm getting down those fast doubles and when I do,
oh boy.
Oh boy.
I still won't have a Gig.
All right.
That fucking ending sucked.
God,
goddammit.
All right.
That's the end of the Monday morning podcast.
Somebody send me an MP.
Three.
I said I was gonna put it up this week.
I just don't have the,
uh,
I don't have the fucking time right now.
Um,
when I get back to La in a couple of weeks,
I'm going to do it.
Somebody made me a new intro and if you guys want to try to come up with an
Intro,
I know I've got some musicians out there who listen to this.
If you want to write an intro song,
somebody,
a long time ago,
some band offered to do that.
And uh,
I never really got back to him.
I think they were from Michigan.
I can't remember.
But,
uh,
if you want to do that,
go ahead now because actually kind of know how to use garageband and I could
kind of splice it together.
Um,
yeah,
and that's it.
So that's it.
People.
Um,
I will be doing standup in New York City.
I actually worked the comedy cellar last a weekend and I might be at comics this
Wednesday,
um,
which that would be June 24th.
I might be doing it,
but there's also a chance that I might be shooting and I might not be there.
So,
uh,
it's day to day,
just like a rough day to day and a Iran,
if you're listening,
I hope you get over your fatigue and I hope he took a nap.
God,
I'm such a [inaudible].
All right.
You guys have a great weekend card tickets.
[inaudible]
so
tons of speech.
I'm speaking
[inaudible].